et c'est lors du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus
à la une ce soir la coupe d'afrique des
nations et la victoire sans forcer de la
côte d'ivoire contre la guinée
équatoriale 1 à 0 nous reviendrons
également sur cet arbitrage
rocambolesque lors du match tunisie mali
la rencontre a été arrêtée avant la fin
du temps réglementaire trouvent au camp
la colère des aigles de carthage
au burkina faso un coup d'état at-il été
déjoué huit militaires ont été mis aux
arrêts accusés d'avoir projeté de
déstabiliser les institutions le chef de
corps du 12e régiment d'infanterie
commando ferait partie des personnes
interpellées cela intervient au moment
où le burkina faso fait face aux
violences djihadistes les détails sur
cette affaire avec le journaliste
abdoulaye barry dont ce journal et puis
nous irons en guinée le pays connaît un
regain de contamination au kobe 19 les
autorités ont durci les mesures de
prévention et veulent mettre un coup
d'accélération à la campagne de
vaccination le reportage à conakry de
nos correspondants à la fin de cette
édition
ils étaient les favoris de cette roue de
cette rencontre les éléphants de côte
d'ivoire n'ont pas failli à leur
réputation ils remportent leur premier
match de cette can face à la guinée
équatoriale 1 but à 0 et on en vient en
ce début d'après midi est compliqué pour
la tunisie le mali c'est la tunisie se
sont affrontés sur la pelouse de libé
dominés 1 à 0 les tunisiens espérait
peut-être une remonte à daha durant le
temps additionnel d'autant qu'il se
trouvait en supériorité numérique après
l'expulsion d'el bilal tour et c'était
sans compter sur le chronomètre quelque
peu défaillant de l' arbitre du match le
zambien gianni et si kazue qui
interrompu la rencontre à deux reprises
avant la fin du temps réglementaire le
résumé de ce match avec cédric ferreira
nous étions dans le stade au moment où
tout cela s'est déroulé tout a commencé
à la 85e minute quand l'arbitré a sifflé
le coup de sifflet final du match à la
stupeur générale devant les protestions
protestation les tunisiens elle s'est
rendu compte de son erreur le match a
repris et puis nouveau coup de théâtre à
30 secondes de la fin du temps
réglementaire alors qu'il restait donc
du temps à jouer plus le temps
additionnel c'était certain et bien
arbitre a sifflé la fin définitive du
match du coup colère immense du staff
tunisiens et des joueurs qui sont rués
sur la pelouse pour protester entourant
larbitre l'arbite qui resté campé sur
ses décisions il a dû même être escortés
pour quitter le terrain devant les
protestations très virulente du staff
tunisien et du coup ensuite il ya eu
encore la confusion dans les vestiaires
puisque la reprise du match a été
annoncée les joueurs maliens sont
revenus sur le terrain pas les tunisiens
qui ont refusé et du coup le le score
final cette victoire 1 0 du mali contre
la tunisie a été entérinée mais
maintenant il va falloir répondre à
toutes ces questions la confédération
africaine de football doit rendre des
comptes au moins ne serait-ce pour
l'équipe de tunisienne de football
comment c'est possible qu'un match
puisse se terminer avant la fin du temps
réglementaire comment ce type d'erreur
est encore possible dans une compétition
d'un tel niveau il faut des réponses à
cette question ne serait ce que pour
l'image du football africain en tout cas
sur le terrain le mali a remporté les
trois points de la victoire il ya très
bien parti pour se qualifier pour les
huitièmes de finale de la compétition il
est certain que cette histoire va faire
parler surtout que l'arbitré avait déjà
fait polémique par le passé c'est le
zambien jany y croiser il avait été
suspendu en 2018 pour des soupçons de
corruption puis il avait été réintégré
par la confédération africaine de
football il avait notamment officié lors
de la dernière coupe d'afrique des
nations en 2019 alors certes ça n'a rien
à voir avec les faits qu'on lui reproche
par le passé mais en tout cas son nom va
forcément faire parler car il est au
centre de cette histoire et de ce match
qui s'est interrompu avant la fin entre
la tunisie et le mali colère et
frustration donc dans le camp tunisien
les aigles de carthage qui ont du mal à
encaisser les décisions de l'arbitré
coûter est ce qu'en disait l'entraîneur
mondher kbaier lors de la conférence de
presse d'après match sincèrement c'est
une situation très difficile à gérer
puisque c'est de l'extra sportif
l'arbitré premier temps ici fait la 85e
minute moins de cinq minutes de jeu
encore une fois ici féline deuxième fois
à la 89e minute
ils nous privent nous prive pratiquement
de sept ou huit minutes de temps
additionnel et à ce moment là ont joué à
11 contre 10
on a pris le dessus au niveau de cette
période qui s'est elle un autre moment
fort
maintenant c'est sa décision
inexplicable
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment
comment il a pris cette décision on va
voir les décisions qu'ils vont suivre
après et même sentiment chez les
supporters qui ont suivi la rencontre à
tunis leur réaction au micro de lilia
blesse
enfin si l'on doit refaire le match
parce que l'arbitrage était injuste je
suis vraiment déçu ce n'est pas normal
ce qui s'est passé
on arbitres qui sifflent la fin de la
partie à la 85e minute et qui sifflent
encore la fin du match à la 89e c'est
quoi ce genre de match
malheureusement ce sont les conditions
dans lesquelles on joue les matchs en
afrique
[Musique]
un arbitre qui à être le match trop tôt
qui s'en va puis qui revient qui ensuite
appelle les joueurs à reprendre le match
c'est n'importe quoi je me demande si la
tunisie peut déposer une plainte au
moins un recours
et puis dans le groupe f en fin
d'après-midi la mauritanie s'est incliné
face à la gambie et scorpions gambiens
qui ont piqué fort en s'imposant 1 but à
0 la rencontre s'est tenue à limay dans
la province du sud-ouest où des
incidents ont été reportés le chef lieu
de la province bauer a connu ce matin
une importante fusillade il y aurait
deux morts civils et plusieurs blessés
dont un grave cette fusillade a opposé
des membres des forces de sécurité
déployées en nombre durant la
compétition et des combattants
séparatistes
sur le plan politique cette fois pour le
mali le pays devrait subir des sanctions
de la part de l'union européenne après
celle infligée par la cedeao c'est ce
qu'annonce le chef de la diplomatie
française elle une réunion se tient
jeudi 6 à brest des ministres européens
et de la défense et des affaires
étrangères nous allons proposer de
soutenir les décisions africaine et de
les reprendre une partie d'entre elles a
déclaré jean yves le drian la france est
bien décidée à mettre la pression sur le
gouvernement malien de transition on
écoute jean yves le drian il n'y a pas
de la france qui est engagée au au mali
et dans les pays du sahel pour lutter
contre le terrorisme il y a dix pays
européens qui sont solidaires et qui
refusent cette cette dérive donc c'est
maintenant à la jeune de prendre ses
responsabilités sinon effectivement il
prend le risque de voir ce pays être
asphyxiées de sa propre responsabilité
et on en vient la situation sécuritaire
au burkina faso alors que le pays est
confronté aux attaques terroristes on
apprend l'arrestation de huit militaires
qui auraient tenté je cite de
déstabiliser les institutions c'est ce
qu'indique le procureur militaire de
ouagadougou écoutez les précisions
d'abdoulaye baril depuis la capitale du
burkina faso le parquet militaire qui
donc avoir été séduit par dénonciation
des membres du militaire qui s'apprête
donc à déstabiliser les institutions de
la république est claire il s'agit d'un
projet de coup d'état visant à renverser
le régime d'europe kaboré élu à la tête
du burkina en 2000 qu'elle est élu en
2000 à l'issue d'élections je dirais que
selon qui sur le papier oui militaires
sont actuellement aux arrêts sans plus
de précisions rappellons que c'est pas
la première fois qu'un coup d'état va
déposer deux coups d'état et des ions
coquilles à la première fois c'était
donc en 2017 et les colonels au curry
avait été accusé de vouloir renverser le
régime de roch kaboré n'a été arrêtée ni
aux arrêts pendant huit mois
si l'on comparé à l'époque avait promis
de les brûler sans délai de la sont koné
burkinabè n'ont toujours pas lui ai
perdu ma vie cela intervient à un moment
difficile pour le gouvernement burkinabè
qui est confronté à de nombreuses
incursions jihadistes dans le nord
oui effectivement que depuis 2000 faire
des bouquets là
le papa est essentielle et donc
aujourd'hui la situation sécuritaire est
très difficile de potinage marqué donc
pas une occupation de certaines zones du
burkina par des troupes d'élite est
aujourd'hui la plus sécuritaire entendu
qu'il y ait ensuite politique optimale
on se rappelle encore au lendemain des
évènements de ce haut la main en juin
dernier où une attaque terroriste avait
occasionné la mort de 38,6 des
manifestants des milliers de
manifestants avaient demandé on peut
être un kaboré d'échanger immédiatement
le ministre de la défense est que de la
sécurité et qui a été fait mais
désormais les manifestants semblent être
montés au créneau pour demander aux
prises avec amour évident de rendre le
tablier de quelque 7 novembre dernier on
se rappelle les musées de manifestants
avaient demandé aux ténors kaboré des
policiers parce que son gouvernement n'a
pas été à même donc d'apporter des
réponses adéquates et on note également
le 22 janvier prochain des
manifestations devrait donc battre le
pavé pour du temps demandé la démission
pure et un petit plus dans kaboré et non
faire un point sur la situation
sanitaire sur le continent la tunisie
durcit ces mesures le pays ray en posant
couvre-feu nocturne de 22h à 5h du matin
pendant deux semaines à partir de jeudi
pour limiter la propagation du
coronavirus autres mesures annoncées qui
fait polémique les l'interdiction de
tous les rassemblements les autorités
demandent d'éviter les déplacements à
l'intérieur du pays sauf en cas
d'urgence des mesures contestées par
l'opposition notamment le parti ennahda
qui maintient son appel à manifester
contre le président vendredi dans la
capitale tunis
et les indicateurs sont au rouge en
guinée où le nombre de cas de vide est
en forte augmentation le variant au
micron a été détecté en fin d'année
depuis jusqu'à 400 cas par jour sont
confirmés le taux d'un film d'incidence
a doublé selon les autorités sanitaires
le pays mise plus que jamais sur la
vaccination à conakry si le reportage de
sarah sakho et malik diakité
principal lieu de traitement des malades
du code vite dans le pays le centre de
beitia en banlieue de conakry est
débordée depuis l'arrivée du variant au
micron fin décembre nos caméras n'ont
pas eu accès aux salles de soins où se
trouve près de 200 malades un chiffre
record pour le docteur condé et son
équipe on a constaté une augmentation
des cas au niveau de la réanimation
parce qu'avant la recrudescence on
n'était qu'à deux factions niveau de
l'animation et aujourd'hui nous sommes à
34 et il le sait nous combinons le
nombre des patients radio malaria est
sorti nous sommes à peu près de 60
patients qui sont venus de l'animation
ça veut dire que vraiment c'était c'est
vraiment sérieux sur les huit décès
enregistrés par le centre depuis
l'arrivée du variant au micron tous sont
des non vaccinés en guinée seule une
personne sur cinq a reçu un sérum selon
des chiffres officiels
fort de ce constat les autorités
renforcent la campagne de vaccination
elle est désormais ouverte aux enfants
âgés de 12 à 17 ans dans ce grand lycée
de la commune de matam en banlieue de la
capitale files heures est proposée aux
élèves mme awa a 16 ans et elle n'a pas
hésité
et l'après midi n'a pas de l'ampleur
l'opération semble être un succès
devant débuter le 7 et à l'engouement
qui à la serva
port obligatoire du masque partout passe
vaccinale requis pour entrer dans les
établissements publics les autorités ont
récemment durci les mesures de
prévention des mesures peut respecter
sur le terrain le professeur traoré qui
coordonne la riposte contre la pandémie
en appel aux populations
en plus du respect des mesures barrières
il faudrait que la population adhère à
la vaccination la vaccination permettra
d'avoir une immunité collective et
lorsque l'immunité collective ra la
réponse sera l'endiguement de la maladie
la guinée espère vacciner 70 % de sa
population dans les prochains mois
et c'est la fin du journal de l'afrique
merci de votre fidélité et merci aux
équipes en régime et à l'édition je vous
retrouve jeudi pour faire le point sur
l'actualité sur le continent en
attendant belle soirée sur france 24
[Musique]
cette semaine un pari d art magique en
compagnie d'eric antoine il nous parlera
de son dernier spectacle grandi un peu
en ce moment aux folies bergère je crois
que je me mets ne se rappelant plus
émotionnel que schirrhein plan physique
nous irons avec lui visité le musée de
l'illusion
et puis une rencontre avec le
photographe sacha goldberger qui nous
fera voyager au coeur de sa création et
livrera lui aussi quelques secrets un
des points communs 7,2 de s'éloigner de
la réalité et de guides amener un peu de
rêve le pari des arts d'eric antoine a
retrouvé très vite sur france 24